apple made an announcement on august 6
that they would be rolling out quote
a system for checking photos for child
abuse imagery on a country by country
basis depending on local laws according
to reuters
this means apple is joining facebook
microsoft and google who have taken
similar virtuous measures nobody wants
to see people trafficking in child
pornography
and if we can stop it and we can catch
these people and put them in jail
that's a fantastic thing for us to do in
society however apple's announcement is
a little different than the other big
tech companies which are scanning
basically the cloud this time apple
seems to be uh screening the photos
before they're uploaded to the cloud now
this is because you need to know the
architecture of this apple has said
we're going to keep all your stuff on
your phone not in our cloud we're going
to be the anti-facebook and the
anti-google we will keep your stuff on
your phone we'll keep it encrypted and
you'll be on your own however what that
does is it triggers a bigger dilemma
which is if you're a terrorist uh if
you're a criminal if you're trafficking
in this kind of horrible content
it's locked up on your phone
so
here comes the back door now if the back
door to the iphone seems familiar it's
because the san bernardino shooting done
by terrorists
was controversial because apple would
not allow a backdoor to be given to the
phone so if you protect people's privacy
with encryption and you don't give back
doors
to that to the government which the
government has always had
then
you
protect individuals privacy in aggregate
but you allow criminals to benefit from
that this is a big dilemma there is no
easy solution here but i think we can
all agree
that if there's a terrorist attack apple
should unlock the damn phone and at the
end period end of story so now we get to
the next thing okay child pornography
seems like an easy one give the
information to the government put these
people in jail should not be
controversial except
that now we have a technological edge
case here the entire
concept of the iphone is that it's its
own black box it's its own black phone
which is what i think the cia and other
intelligent agencies call these phones
their phones that can't be unlocked
can't be unencrypted you get the idea
and so according to the ap
here's how the technology works it's
using something called neural match
which is designed to detect images of
sexual abuse of children and it scans
for these images before they are
uploaded to icloud while still on the
device if the technology locates a match
the photo in question will be reviewed
by a human if child porn is confirmed
the user account will be disabled and
the national center for missing and
exploited children will be notified i
also think there's some database of
child pornography that is also scanned
for them i don't know what that's called
but i remember reading about that in a
wired story as i believe here's the
reuters quote apple says will only scan
in the united states and other countries
to be added one by one because obviously
laws will be different in different
places but according to the reuters
story in an internal slack channel 800
messages long many apple employees spoke
out against the plan as told to reuters
by an anonymous employee who saw the
thread
now again back to the slack channels and
the discussions 800 messages not a lot
of messages or slack channel and we
don't know how many employees are in
here reuters doesn't have that
information so there's no context we
don't know if this was 10 people in
there doing 800 messages 800 people
doing one message we don't know if it
was one person who was upset and is like
a super
privacy nut or if there are 800 privacy
nuts at apple who are going after this
and we don't know the denominator we
don't know how many employees uh there
are who have access to this room or
whatever tech feature analyst jane m
wong who is the woman that always scoops
twitter's new features if you remember
she tweeted the following i am concerned
apple cannot and will not say
no to potential requests from china
given the market in factories and that
is something i've been talking about on
this program for a long time which is in
other countries is another key angle of
the story
which is in countries that tell you give
us the entire icloud of everybody which
is china and they're probably doing this
and they're definitely doing the same
with tick tock in my mind there's no
question so every piece of information
on tick tock is now on china servers if
tiktok has access to your entire photo
library and you have things in your
photo library you don't want shared i
bet the chinese government has it now if
you're the son of a senator or
congressman or the president and you
have things on your phone the chinese
government has it they now blackmail the
senator hey we have the nudes of your
child
or whatever it happens to be and uh
hunter biden anybody this is actually
happening this is not there's some kind
of hypothetical situation here where
somebody could be blackmailed or it
could cause political interference so
there are genuine concerns here and if
there's anything that can be learned
from that it's that these issues are not
going to be easy to solve
especially not for apple who now wants
to have the high ground on privacy but
they're now proven that they can stay on
your phone and deliver stuff for me
any way to catch these people i'm for
period end of story i i know that might
be controversial coming from a tech
person but i also think they should
unlock the san bernardino phone sorry if
you disagree with that i understand why
you disagree with it i'm sure i'll
debate it with my besties on the all-in
podcast but when it comes to certain
crimes
like this and terrorism i have zero
sympathy and i'm willing to give up some
of my privacy in order to have that
happen i know that's a risk that's a
controversial thing for a tech person to
say but i trust apple maybe i'm stupid
but i do have some trust for that brand
and for that come but i do think
directionally apple is correct in what
they're doing and i do think anybody
who's nervous about their privacy is
also correct it is possible for both of
these things
that seem
to be in conflict or actually correct
you're right to be worried about your
privacy and you have every right to be
worried about your privacy and concern
that apple has such sophisticated
technology to do this and
you could also agree that apple should
do this
and that controls need to be in place
and we have to really think this through
because it's going to get worse and
worse as time goes on and these are not
easy issues from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business blog or publish
content promote your business announce
upcoming events or special projects and
sell products and services of all kinds
and more they also have powerful
ecommerce functionality and everything
is optimized for mobile right out of the
box so no matter what you're using an
ipad
a surface
iphone an android phone it doesn't
matter all these beautiful templates
just work and of course it's got
built-in seo free and secure hosting and
24 7 award-winning customer support we
did remote demo day in 2020 we were
suffering through the pandemic we were
confused how are these startups going to
get funded i say throw up a squarespace
site it's a project maybe it turns into
a business and boy did it ever we have
now funded over
a dozen companies over 14 million
dollars in funding and this all from
setting up a simple squarespace website
and tweeting it so go to squarespace.com
twist for a free trial squarespace.com
slash twist for a free trial when you're
ready to launch use the offer code twist
and save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain and congratulations
for the team uh going public by direct
listing on may 19th what an amazing
journey it's been congratulations again
you